Axel
there was just as much action behind the
scenes as on screen with camera people
running around and intense visual
effects being produced live
[Music]
[Applause]
the glass stones ending definitely
caught us off guard but the process to
capture the way it surprised Guion
sebiak and sang woo was an extensive one
filming the actors only had a small
amount of glass explode near them the
slow motion feeling really comes through
and how the actors perform
after capturing shots of the trio each
got to do their close-up work with
singles as well it may be a short moment
but plenty of hours were put into
capturing every nuance and angle
when time came for the big visual of the
glass Stepping Stones we see exploding
the team didn't resort to CGI for the
shards of glass except for the ones that
appeared to harm the players and fly
towards the camera they actually went
ahead and created the whole sequence in
studio these practical effects look
unreal on the set it's no surprise it
translates to such a powerful and
stunning visual in the episode
hello players let me welcome you all to
the fifth game
the cast of squid game Dove right in
when playing glass stepping stones and
definitely didn't have it easy since for
many it was actually terrifying to film
while CGI came into play in terms of
establishing the setting and just how
high in the air the players were much of
the carnival-like set was fully built
even the glass fortunately no one
actually went through shattering glass
instead landing on a board supported by
a crew to allow the actor to fall safely
in the show the set that red light green
light takes place on already seems
awfully crowded with the nearly 500
players but on the set there were even
more folks making it a pretty chaotic
yet well-organized space we would have
thought CGI was used to add the bodies
of those who lost during the game
especially the piles of people at the
doors but the actors all actually stayed
wherever they were when they lost the
game which couldn't have been very
comfortable when it came to filming
close-ups multiple cameras were used to
capture the performances and the filming
crew was often running along with the
players the added detail of using a red
marker to Signal when a person took a
shot is evident of just how thorough and
meticulous the team was no one could get
away with cheating during the game
either if one person moved out of time
we're looking at you sang woo then
everyone had to start over
today's game is tug of war
the performers did not have it easy
playing the often physically demanding
games when filming the series since they
really were going through the struggle
depicted on screen the sweat effort and
even chained handcuffs securing them to
the Rope were real there definitely
couldn't be much movement between tanks
since everyone was literally tied up
together with a scene like this there
isn't really any other way to do it than
at 100 percent
before you die maybe one of the most
terrifying gasp worthy moments in the
show is seeing Guion hanging between
safety and the end of the game for his
whole team the tension is real even
though the platform they were on was
just a meter and a half off the ground
while swinging on a rope is usually
pretty fun this Collective ropes swing
down tells a very different story and
shows just how far the actors and
production went to bring the best
footage to the screen oh my God I can't
believe how cool that was the moment
after the most intense tug of war we've
ever seen is so still but we can see
just how exhausted each and every actor
is having just struggled and fought for
their lives literally this shot is
definitely needed as a moment of pause
after the insane game just played
resulting in so many lives lost this is
also a bit of a moment of Reckoning this
was hard but whatever was coming next
would only be harder and they knew it
what I I really thought we were going to
die out there for the final Face-Off The
Sound Stage was a lot emptier with just
Guion and sang woo competing but there
were many camera people often filming
using handheld video cameras to capture
all the Frantic action not only that
their crew made it rain making the whole
scene just as dramatic as the gruesome
fight we see in the Final Cut as filming
went on the two actors only got more
disheveled with Reigns soaking through
and blood effects added throughout the
battle in order to get all the footage
they needed the actors had to be on
point at every moment
I will let you let you that money the
honeycomb scenes looked pretty similar
on set as they did in the show with the
exception of the childlike drawn
wallpaper the rest of the set was filled
with giant playground equipment and the
smell of freshly made Algona the Korean
honeycomb Suite luckily the actors
didn't have to listen to the actual loud
noise each time a bullet was fired as
someone on set was in charge of giving a
shout to indicate the moment instead so
the performers had a solid unified cue
to react to
behind the scenes we get a glimpse of
just how Hands-On the director was when
it came time to shoot
foreign
ly the cavernous cool space where we see
the confrontation between the police
officer and a team member of the squid
game is real the opening on the top of
the cave and the murky pool made the
ideal setting no doubt the actors felt
totally immersed in the story shooting
these scenes were pretty simple all they
needed were a couple of cameras the
right costumes and the actors chilling
performances
do you want to die
the glimpses we get of the players as
lives before the game offers such a
colorful backstory especially when we
see them with their families each of
these scenes were shot quite intimately
and simply focusing on the narrative and
what these relationships meant to the
player which translated to the screen
beautifully it's also one of the only
times we get to see a typical everyday
aesthetic making the stark contrast
between the real world and the squid
game world even more apparent
which color do you want to play as
how could we forget the original squid
game filming this scene may have been
one of the simplest setups using an
existing playground space it only adds
to the realism of the show and offers a
great reminder of where the players
started as innocent children playing
games for fun instead of their lives
at that moment I felt as if I owned the
entire world hanging out in the dorms
between games certainly wasn't any less
stressful than the games themselves
The Bare Bones set with the cool
industrial Edge does the trick and the
feeling of the daunting space comes
through the screen what we saw in the
show was almost exactly what was
happening on set with all the added
cameras and crew people of course
we can't fall asleep tonight okay who
knows what someone else may try many
moments in the marbles game bring
intense connection and emotion the way
they shot these scenes was a pretty
Stark difference from so many of the
large and intense games the fact that
the actors were in a small space
together with just a few crew members
around really helps the intimacy come
through and offers us the chance to get
up close and personal with these
characters and the short but meaningful
relationship they have playing marbles
one of the reasons the marbles game is
so effective is because of just how well
the setting transports us to the alleys
of a small village it makes sense that
this is the set the team spent the most
time building every detail down to the
stunning backdrops moves us
[Music]
super powered Umbrella Academy wouldn't
be the same without some seriously
powerful VFX the team behind the show
put in some incredible work to bring our
favorite moments to the screen
number one
the Epic finale of season 2 required a
lot of impressive VFX work you know
you're right let's change that when
Handler summons 8 000 agents they are
almost entirely CGI doubles with only a
handful of them being real extras they
filmed on set to make this process even
more difficult it started snowing
halfway through their filming of the
scene so some of the extras that they
originally had didn't show up again
forcing the VFX team to fix continuity
issues via CGI when the agents charge
the house and then subsequently get
blasted those shots are almost
completely CGI as well with the
exception of a few small elements and
the house itself it was really really
complicated how are they doing then
number two
Pogo the chimp looked incredible and was
a testament to how talented the team at
what a digital is they were tasked with
creating this character and didn't shy
away from The Challenge there is a
certain challenge in making something
subtly believable the VFX team knew how
important it was to create realistic
clothing for PoGo so they actually
developed a new software specifically
for making the most realistic clothing
possible when it came time to filming
Pogo scenes they actually used two
actors for different aspects of the
character's performance actor Ken Hall
was on set in a motion capture suit
interacting with other characters and
providing the body movements for PoGo
meanwhile Adam Godley lent his voice to
the character does anyone wish to speak
and did so in a studio where they also
captured his facial performance to give
Pogo the Final Touch of real emotion
number three
one of the most complex shots the bfx
team had to execute was when we see the
members of the Umbrella Academy all
dancing alone in their rooms they shot
the actors individually on green screen
and then placed them into the scene
which aside from the actors themselves
was a full CG animation what's more it
was the first day of shooting for many
of the cast members I feel like we
really had an energy together that that
worked number four
when we first meet Luther we see him
casually going about his day on the moon
it's no surprise they didn't actually
film on the moon but it may surprise you
that almost everything you see is CGI
actor Tom Hopper was filmed on a green
screen while being suspended with wires
to simulate the weightlessness of space
very few elements were practical and
most of the time the only real aspect is
Luther and a part of his space suit even
his helmet was CGI
number five
the epic war scene at the beginning of
season 2 was brought to life with a mix
of impressive practical set pieces and
Visually stunning CGI a lot of the
rubble and debris on the ground was real
while the buildings and all the action
happening in the sky was CGI and that
tank rolling down the street that was
real the shell shot out of it was CG
animation as was when Banya stopped at
midair Elia page was lifted into the air
on wires and shot on a green screen to
create the effect of her character
stopping the missile put it all together
and the result is an epic scene what the
hell was that
into the world November 25th 1963.
number six
when you have a character that has a
humanoid body with a fishbowl head that
contains a real live goldfish you have
to get creative in bringing said
character to life when filming they had
an actor wearing the suit and bottom
collar piece of the bowl we see in the
show with his head later being replaced
with a CGI Fishbowl they did have a
fishbowl head-on set for reference but
it was only on a stick and didn't
contain any water or fish what a digital
the studio behind the fish effects
bought real goldfish and kept them as
pets what a digital did a phenomenal job
making it happen
surely we can come to some form of
agreement that benefits both parties
number seven when we see the
commission's inner workings we are
introduced to an infinite room of
workers being tired of something
so Grand that shows the massive scale of
the organization in real life the room
is much less impressive they shot the
scene in a small room with only a few
desk workers in front of a green screen
they expanded the size of the room with
CGI and added hundreds of more desk
workers to achieve the scale they were
going for
who was the case manager handling me
[Music]
number eight
when Klaus summons his ghost friends you
can rest easy knowing they're not real
ghosts and are instead the work of CGI
artists in the season 1 finale and at
the beginning of season two ghost Ben is
completely CGI and when Ben is trying to
get out of Klaus actor Robert Sheehan
was acting alongside no one and had to
do his best to pretend to be pushing a
ghost back into his body we hope you
enjoyed that as much as we did number
nine
all of the JFK scenes in season 2 were
almost completely CGI in some of the
wide City shots the buildings motorcade
and even the people are CGI when Banya
destroys the FBI building Elia page was
on wires on a green screen set and even
then they were mostly replaced with CGI
anyway and when Klaus tackles the man
with the umbrella the motorcade behind
him and all the people in the background
are CGI when I use extras when you have
an amazing VFX team
number 10.
Reginald Hargreaves revealing himself as
an alien is a shocking twist we didn't
see coming for the reveal they built a
mask that resembled confior's face and
had the actor unzip it and peel it off
his head underneath the Mast on his real
head he wore a motion capture cap the
CGI alien head was added later on to
complete the reveal
number 11.
the effects team spent a lot of time
developing all the warp and wave effects
caused by the powers from the characters
5 jumping through time Allison's powers
and vanya's blast waves all use the same
type of viscous effect VFX supervisor
Everett Burrell described the effect as
going into and coming out of a bowl of
jelly because of this the team
appropriately named the effect jelly
Vision we use my ability to time travel
but this time I'll take you with me
number 12.
the scenes with Klaus and his Colts
involved a mixture of practical and
digital effects the bus scenes were
filmed on a big blue screen with fans
used to simulate wind the city of
Varanasi was added using CGI number 13.
a lot of CGI was used during the white
violin final battle in season one
fania's transformation into the white
violin was accomplished using bright
lights on set which were enhanced with a
CGI glow that was added in later the
theater was at times a real set and
other times they used a CGI version of
it like when the explosion comes through
which was also a CGI simulation
number 14. the Epic shot was created
with both practical and digital effects
they filmed it on a giant outdoor set
that had a lot of real debris
surrounding actor Aiden Gallagher there
was a small green screen behind
Gallagher and the rest of the
environment was filled in digitally
anyone
number 15.
the unleashing of vanya's powers for the
first time was a big moment for the
character Elliot page was filmed alone
on a green screen while the camera
rotated around them the rain and the
environment were added digitally the
result was the first display of vanya's
true powers
foreign despite trying to avoid it as
much as possible The Witcher is filled
with CGI from entire cities to
Prosthetics to the Magical elements
we'll be taking a look at it all check
it out
I believe there are 133 shots in that
sequence and 132 of them involve VFX
number one you gotta do what you gotta
do this is the moment before we meet our
friends the basilisks as they appear
through a portal While most of the scene
leading up to this shot isn't CGI it's
quite understandable why a green screen
may have come in handy trying to be all
stoic and serious and then there's a guy
in in green spandex number two here come
the terrifying lime green lizard heads
you've really gotta be willing to
pretend as an actor sometimes especially
in the fantasy genre you know it's going
to look awesome in the end but honestly
sometimes it's hard to take your job
seriously when you're trying to be all
stoic and serious and your acting
partner is supposed to be a scary
basilisk but instead is just a bright
green head on a stick operated by a guy
in spandex
I sometimes would giggle but with
imagination on their side they manage I
love The Illusion world I love to be
visualize everything number three if we
turned people into trees we could solve
climate change think about it Paul
bullion took on the role of aleshi in
season two the entirety of the leshi's
face is all Prosthetics which is pretty
sweet we can't imagine how long that
took to apply every day all of the vines
growing off of his head though is where
the CGI magic comes in and who is geralt
attacking that doesn't look like aleshi
to us nope just a guy flinging around a
pool noodle okay it's probably not a
pool noodle
before we started filming we had to do
quite a bit of training Number Four The
Grass Is Always Green screened somewhere
else we spotted some green screens in
the training scenes too trying to block
out their not so perfect location to
replace it with their Mountaintop
destination later on also is it just us
or are the green ropes new they must be
way easier to edit out in post than the
black ones and if you look closely Freya
Allen really isn't dodging a thing
I love all the stunt stuff it's so much
fun
number five beautifying the Beast you
might be surprised to find out that the
creation of nivlin required little CGI
he was dressed in full costume the only
CGI was his face and I have like tons of
dots and and a camera all the time but
Christopher have you absolutely loves
that his eyes are his own how they made
the eyes look like mine is just
beautiful work so why the CGI and not
just prosthetics
said that a reason
it's emotion but he needed to Justified
and it looked great
number six two halves is more effective
than one this scene from episode one of
The Witcher is probably a personal fave
it isn't often an actor does all of his
own stunts and check out how he's only
got half a sword that's how he managed
to do some of these cool more dangerous
Maneuvers in one shot it allows for a
lot more moves although the other actors
did find it a bit of a struggle because
they needed to match their weapons with
the invisible half of the sword
perfectly number seven if the sword
doesn't work try hitting him with a shoe
Vladimir furtick who played the night
King in Game of Thrones choreographed
the fight between geralt and the
kikimura he acted out the scenes he was
choreographing by standing four people
on a table and giving them each a pair
of pipes to act as legs animating two
legs is hard enough let alone eight they
had to watch the footage at a quarter
speed to make sure it was moving
properly Julian Perry confessed it was
tricky to keep the creature balanced and
attacking at the same time and who could
forget all that splashing that's all CGI
too number eight this next one's pretty
hot magic is definitely one of those
elements that is hard to create without
special effects and a lot of CGI tricks
went into shooting this scene the
warping skin trick is done using a whole
bunch of different mask-like layers in
different stages of Decay and just
blending them all together it makes
total sense but how come we never
thought of that before and check out all
of the work that goes into making the
fireballs and how about how they're
launching people across the room
why does that look like so much fun
number nine the creature that feeds on
nightmares did this trigger creep you
out as much as it did us well the entire
costume was Prosthetics including the
dangly umbilical cord overall the
character required a blend of CGI too
they completely redesigned the character
out of special effects for some of the
more inhuman stunts we'd say it's
impressive but we know your tricks CGI
designers you have your character hide
in the darkness to make it easier to
blend the CGI with the real effects and
the actors were having a blast they had
three artists playing the role Becky
Wright played the human form but they
had two other performers playing the
creature number 10 we actually preferred
the little guys with their green suits
showing to our surprise the ghouls were
not totally made of CGI the proof is in
the Selfies pull some content alert oh
how cute are these boy does that suit
look uncomfortable though and eating
looks like a major struggle they were
running out of time to craft these
scenes which is why they landed on a
halfway point between Prosthetics and
special effects number 11. literal World
building it's actually amazing the kind
of work that goes into creating the
buildings for fantasy series remember
how much time you would spend building
your dream house in The Sims or even a
small community
this is like next level Sims right here
number 12. ironically nothing about this
nature is real layer after layer after
layer added on painstakingly to bring
this Forest to life not even geralt and
roach are real here just leads you to
wonder is anything real just kidding and
like let's talk about Posada that too
was entirely modeled from scratch the FX
supervisor Julian Perry said almost
every minute of this series is a visual
treat which means it required you
guessed it CGI as finding that perfect
location was a struggle given they were
filming in Budapest in the middle of
winter
there's no cutting Corners with crafting
these CGI Bad Boys
now these guys seem like they're a
little lacking in the detail department
but we still like them well enough what
they lack in CGI they sure do make up in
storytelling layers it's all layers bone
structure muscle skin they definitely
weren't skipping steps when they created
him except for maybe the scales and all
these layers remind us of a line from
Shrek onions have layers ogres have
layers well dragons have layers too and
lots of them number 14 we're gonna need
some CGI sleevees to go with these CGI
armies only about 30 or so people were
real out of this entire Army do you
think they craft every tiny person by
hand or do you think they have a copy
paste button drawing a picture is hard
enough let alone layer after layer of
Designing creatures and buildings we'll
stick to pencil crayons and stick
figures thank you very much me and a
couple other guys crawling around on the
floor growling at each other that was
weird I'll never forget that are you
curious about how all the effects were
done in Wednesday well we've got some
secrets to spill about thing Nevermore
Academy and all of the featured
creatures
hello thing number one everyone's
favorite hand is actually attached to a
full-grown man the extremely discreet
and talented Victor dorobantu wears a
full-bodied blue suit to create the
effect of the amputated hand his scenes
involved him twisting and contorting
into hard to reach places often times
crawling on the ground and hiding behind
Jenna Ortega sometimes he would have the
luxury of getting wheeled alongside her
on a camera Dolly check out the way this
underwater scene was filmed fun fact
Victor dorobantu and Christopher Hart
the actor who played thing in the 90s
are both magicians apparently it was
very important for the character of
thing to have dexterity which was one of
the main reasons Victor was cast
surrender
[Music]
number two remember when she dropped
piranhas in the pool yeah they had to do
a little bit of special effects on the
roof of the school to make it a little
less Normy the school is called
polytechnica University of Bucharest and
it was founded in 1818 the swimming pool
though is filmed at a sports park in a
completely different location in
Bucharest
I'm not sure whose Twisted idea it was
to put hundreds of adolescents in
underfunded schools number three this
would be the monster that Wednesday is
desperate to find the identity of the
Hide was crafted completely with CGI to
achieve that bulging-eyed razor-sharped
tooth and massive Hawking monster
antagonist created by Tim Burton he was
based on a drawing that Tim Burton
designed before shooting even started he
brought a few drawings to the writer's
room and the writers all
enthusiastically agreed on the Hyde
drawing what really went on behind the
scenes while shooting was a lot
different than what we saw on screen the
hide consisted of a man in a full-bodied
black suit with tracking marks all over
it propped up on stilts with crutches
attached to his arms to portray the
massive size of the monster in real time
seeing the much less frightening costume
that Jenna Ortega really had to react to
we're even more impressed by her
performance number four obviously Oliver
Watson isn't a real merman but he's an
excellent swimmer what really went down
in this scene was half practical and
half special effects Oliver Watson
really did swim underwater but instead
of a full-length mermaid tail he just
had on a regular flipper to assist him
in the water as you can see from that
behind the scenes clip he's extremely
comfortable in the water and was
definitely the right choice to
accomplish Bianca in her pokeup scheme
you can even see his mermaid contacts as
he does a short video with the cast
thanks
number five also known as kanta kuzino
Castle this stunning Romanian Castle got
a spooky makeover to play the role of
Nevermore Academy the castle is actually
pretty inviting when looking at the
exteriors and the bright red roof but
the creators of the show thought the
roof didn't quite match that kooky Adams
Family Vibe so they built on top of it
with special effects you will love
Nevermore
of course you will number six remember
that time Wednesday was almost ended
like 10 minutes after she stepped on
campus though the scene was definitely a
lot safer behind the scenes it really
wasn't all that safe Jenna Ortega's
stunt double Jenny Ayumi was really
under the gargoyle and it really did
crash down but with little intermission
in between the gargoyle drops down
attached to a wire the stunt takes place
when she is shoved out of the way
number seven Rowan was definitely
binging stranger things before this in
the scene where he slams Wednesday up
against a tree he gets help from a few
wires behind the scenes and luckily
Jenna Ortega gets a nice mat to soften
the impact they practiced this stunt
with her stunt double beforehand to make
sure it was safe enough for her to
perform I give stunt coordinators such
immense anxiety Jenna was extremely
adamant about doing as many stunts as
she could I will throw myself on the
floor off a wall number eight though
you'd think after two hits were take
taken on Wednesday's life she'd want an
hour or two of therapy but clearly she
has better things to do Jenny Ayumi
fearlessly hops down from the rooftop
and makes sliding down the side of a
building on a wire look easier than it
possibly ever should number nine no
wires just Talent the intense fencing
battle between Wednesday and Bianca was
a stellar introduction to their complex
friendship you must be the
self-appointed queen bee interesting
thing about these pull out their
stingers and they drop dead okay the
word friendship might be an
overstatement but regardless we get an
incredible stunt sequence out of this
classmate conflict your face finally got
that splash of color it's so desperately
needed number 10 some of it was out of
Lake and some of it wasn't the PO cup
was filmed across two lakes in Romania
but there was also a set built at Buffet
Studios there were even some pretty
hilarious mishaps that happened while
shooting causing the entire cast to need
a major wardrobe change this is what
could have happened if thing hadn't
saved the day by decking Kent in the
face
[Music]
number 11. we're talking about
werewolves of course when Enid gets a
visit from her parents she stares in
Envy at the pack she so desperately
wants to be part of we can't really
blame her though these guys can actually
catch frisbees in their mouths that's
pretty impressive the only thing they
really needed assistance with was
getting high enough in the air nothing a
simple trampoline can't fix otherwise a
completely practical stunt number 12.
the quad Goes Up in Flames in the finale
crackstone wasted no time after being
resurrected from the grave
in the show the fire starts off from
this massive explosion courtesy of crack
Stone's magic but behind the scenes it's
much calmer it's clear that the
production crew wanted a safe
explosionless set so CGI definitely came
in handy for that we also get to see
Bianca's incredible wire stunt where she
stands up to crack Stone talk about a
character Arc number 13 poor mayor Noble
Walker the mayor ends up getting hit by
a car sending Wednesday's investigation
in a whole new Direction in the show you
can't even tell that this was a
professionally performed stunt it looks
like he actually gets hit but if you
watch the behind the scenes footage
close enough you can fully see the
little jump onto the hood of the car
causing for a safe performance who did
you think it was behind the wheel when
you saw the first episode blue Cadillac
with no license plates yeah I know
number 14 you'd be surprised how minimal
the CGI was to build the town of Jericho
just little enhancements here and there
to breathe more life into the town it
was impressively built from scratch at
the famous Buffet Studios Eastern
Europe's largest Film Studio it was
supposed to look like a typical New
England town you can see they didn't
spare any details really honing on the
church steeple as it plays a huge role
in the big explosion scene all of the
other stores and shops the florist shop
cobbler shop and thrift store were
actually facades based on Charles Adams
original illustrations number 15 don't
worry we're pretty sure they had faces
behind the scenes these faceless
characters definitely add a touch of
Nevermore spookiness that's so subtle
they're almost easy to miss the way they
achieved this faceless look was by using
a planner tracker to track the actors
faces and facial movements they then
used editing software to remove their
eyes and mouths isolating those images
and placing them onto the facial data
saved for the planner tracker and what
did you think about Wednesday CGI and
special effects it's pretty incredible
how many things were completely
practical from The Sword fights the
major stunts the PO cup and of course
thing what part of the movie Magic was
your favorite you're gonna see besides
of her in this series that you've never
seen before are you ready to find out
everything we know about Wednesday atoms
like did you know Tim Burton hand-picked
the entire cast or that Jenna Ortega
performed her own stunts and got to work
with the OG Wednesday Christina Ricci
and now the suspense is killing you
number one how many times did you see
Wednesday bling there are little
Wednesday mannerisms sprinkled
throughout Jenna's performance that only
super Keen eyes would be able to see
it's funny I think my posture has
improved immensely since working on that
job her posture was always perfect and
her arms and hands stay pretty
stationary most of the time at some
point during the first couple weeks of
shooting I did a take where I did not
blink at all Tim Burton loved that take
so he and Jenna decided that it would be
one of Wednesday's weird mannerisms she
didn't even know she was doing it half
the time it just sort of happened every
time she would reset for a take I would
drop all the muscles in my face and Tim
really liked the Kubrick stare where I
stared through my eyebrows number two
Jenna was in a Non-Stop cycle of work
for eight months straight we're talking
a minimum of 12-hour work days I would
wake up around 4 30 I would be picked up
around 5 20 ish by 6am she's in wardrobe
by 6 30 she's inherent makeup and by 8
AM she's on set you would do 12-hour
days we would have rolling lunches so we
just eat when we could then in the
evening by around six o'clock she's in
stunt rehearsal because on top of all
this she's doing her own stunts and
fight sequences more on this later and
then I might have a cello lesson and
then I go home that was my day that was
my life for eight months in Romania
number three the shoot days were extra
long for a reason Tim Burton and Jenna
Ortega wanted to do as many different
takes as possible to really nail down
Wednesday's characterization for every
single scene and every single one of
these takes were on camera we are hoping
to see an extended edition with all the
bloopers looking at you Tim number four
her hair was one of the most important
factors everyone knows Wednesday Adams
as the girl with the signature long dark
braids but it was important to Tim
Burton to establish some sort of
difference between who she was then and
who she is now they did a lot of
experimentation with different wigs and
clips but in the end Jenna Ortega being
as dedicated as she is offered up
something invaluable so hey maybe maybe
just cut my actual hair she was and they
did and then he loved it and that was
something that that we married and we
stuck to number five there's major sword
fighting and fencing going on in this
show one of the things that makes Jenna
Ortega so incredible is the dedication
she gives to her work she spent so many
hours training to perfect her fencing
and sword fighting skills so she could
perform her own stunts there was really
important physical aspects like that
like the fencing that I knew that I
wanted to do myself and and have
ownership of number six 20 minutes of
winging it the audition process was over
Zoom as Jenna was in New Zealand filming
X she hadn't slept in 24 hours and
described her audition process as being
tired enough to wing it the audition
only took 20 minutes soon after she had
to pack up and move to Romania for eight
months when you're approached with a
character like this and a director like
this and a story like this it's very
compelling you don't know when you're
going to get the opportunity to do
something like that again I knew that I
just had to take it number seven every
single detail was intentional when
creating Wednesday's look no detail was
too small the show's creators had a lot
to say about her look everything about
her look was intentional Wednesday's
shoes for example our next level every
teenage girl in the world is going to
have serious shoe Envy once they see
them when you first see Wednesday she's
in her iconic white collared black dress
outfit but then as The Show Goes On Her
Style evolves they always wanted her to
stand out from the crowd in some way
number eight one of the most important
factors of the show's look Romania is
not a location that you'll often see in
the media so capturing that grandiose
Eastern European Vibe was a huge
inspiration for both the cast and crew I
did send a photograph of myself in my
office to my agent and said is this what
your office looks like number nine there
are a lot of subtleties to Jenna
Ortega's performance Wednesday is
somebody that I always was compared to
my entire life though the showrunners
found her to be a perfect fit for the
character she was nervous to portray her
because she wanted so badly to do the
character Justice I went to fencing
lessons twice a week
I went to cello lessons twice a week
everywhere she went she would walk like
Wednesday she thought people would think
she was insane with how much she was
putting into nailing down the character
I wanted her to be specific and certain
and assertive number 10. Tim Burton had
a very specific vision for Wednesday
according to Jenna he was one of the
most detail-oriented directors she'd
ever worked with the thing that makes
Tim a great visual director is that he
has an amazing sense of color and style
he liked to have a say in how every shot
was framed and even the type of lens
used on the camera because he kind of
liked when they were wide and a bit
disoriented he designed and brought to
life every single character with
sketches goth comes to him very
naturally and Tim designed what the
Monster looks like in the show number 11
what kind of show would this be without
the appearance of the original Wednesday
Addams Christina Ricci joins the cast as
Marilyn Thornhill a teacher at Nevermore
Academy it is scary it's a lot of
pressure and you you want to do justice
to someone like her you would think that
Jenna and Christina would be having some
pretty intense conversations about the
character they've both portrayed right
the strange thing is we never talked
about her being Wednesday once there was
only one time on the last day of
shooting that Jenna made a reference to
Christina's version of Wednesday they
both had an understanding and an
acceptance that their versions were
going to be different number 12 did you
know Jenna always wanted to star in a
silent film it is a hard thing to play
with an expressionless character the
origin of most of Wednesday's mannerisms
and movements came from the idea of it
being shot like a silent film I felt
like that really encouraged mannerisms
or kind of balance the aspects of
surrealism and realism in the film Tim
Burton really connected with the idea as
well given the fact that the way Jenna
conveyed him motion most of the time was
silently through her Expressions because
they can be very theatrical and dramatic
and intense and that is what Adam's
family is number 13 Wednesday was
originally a Latina character in The
Addams Family Comics one of the most
important parts of this role for Jenna
Ortega was getting to represent
Wednesday as a Latina because it has
never been done before any time that I
have an opportunity to represent my
community I want that to be seen another
way Tim Burton wanted to make this known
was by exemplifying the fact that the
Adams Family participates in Dia de los
Muertos I was just in the living room
more seating for a year-long Dia de los
Muertos number 14 the entire town was
built from the ground up coupled with
the extraordinary setting of Romania the
set of the show was like a character in
itself Gwendolyn Christie talks about
her experience at New York Comic-Con
what I loved was that we filmed in
Romania so you have Landscapes that had
not been seen before it's almost like
looking at things with quite a fresh
pair of eyes on an epic scale and much
of what you see is real this team really
went all out they built a town and used
locations and there's an awful lot of
authenticity to bring that very specific
culture to life number 15 can you
imagine getting an email from Tim Burton
Jenna was busy filming the horror movie
X as conversations about Wednesday
started to come up at Netflix Tim Burton
was the one who thought about her for
the role as he was a fan of her work so
he sent her an email asking if they
could meet I kind of felt like I was
being pranked or something naturally
everyone fell in love with her
performance right away because I'm very
dry and I don't think people can tell
when I'm being serious or when I'm being
sarcastic with Tim Burton behind the
show along with his incredible
hand-picked cast and crew Wednesday is
an iconic piece of media in the making
this is sandman being made for people
who love Sandman by people who love
salmon we're getting into all the
challenges and behind the scenes visions
of everything that brought this incred
incredible series to the Silver Screen
I'm here at shepparton Studios and I'm
getting to see what happens when you
bring dreams to life number one Tom
storage who plays dream was basically
naked for the entirety of the first
episode the way he was first introduced
to his fellow castmates was naked
climbing into a glass sphere and because
of the way the sphere was designed they
couldn't open it super easily so he
would be in there by himself for hours
at a time one aspect he loved about that
though was how that really helped him
get into character in that silence you
can only ever really believe yourself to
be a character number two speed speaking
of getting into character one thing Tom
really struggled with was being
introduced as a protagonist who doesn't
speak or even move much for that matter
it was incredibly important to me to
somehow articulate this otherworldliness
he had a lot to convey with just his
body and facial expressions while using
no words he needed to show the audience
that he wasn't human he was an eternal
being who spent his every fiber holding
all these universes dreams together
that's a lot of pressure with no
dialogue I did work very hard hopefully
to create an image that would tell an
audience that story with no words number
three the realm of Lucifer Morningstar
the VFX team spent more time on this
episode than any other episode there are
so many incredible practical effects the
gate for example is an actual sculpture
at first they didn't even know if they
should show the set on screen VFX
supervisor Ian Markowitz tells Dan of
geek anything that we show of Lucifer's
Palace is going to be disappointing no
matter what it is no matter how cool it
is whatever we show was going to be a
little underwhelming but it turned out
to be their most rewarding episode they
ended up utilizing real life images like
the Vatican and a specific cathedral in
Milan as inspiration number four so much
was actually built practically our heart
Department are set decorators our
production designers they are Wizards it
was really important to Neil Gaiman and
the rest of the show's creators that
whenever they could create or build
something they would do it there's
actually not a ton of CGI in the show
compared to what you might think they
even had a real raven on set it didn't
speak unfortunately but Tom did get to
interact with a real live bird having a
raven there was amazing just something
that you're talking it's like number
five who else is a fan of despair's
Crocs for starters Jenna Coleman's
character Joanna went through almost a
dozen different costume iterations
before they landed on her iconic trench
coat look also I got really over excited
about having a crucifix in my boot for
Tom sturbridge's costume design they
also went through a few different looks
at first he just wanted to be as true to
the comic book character as he could get
and I wanted my hair to be wild and I
wanted my eyes to be as dark as night
but obviously that's not the dream we
ended up with Neil would agree with me
is I looked ridiculous they ended up
sticking with Tom's more natural luck as
they found that to be a better fit for
the screen number six we've gotta talk
about Matthew considering they really
wanted to take a mostly practical effect
with this show they definitely wanted
their CGI to be as top-notch as possible
Ian Markowitz shared his story in
creating Matthew with den of geek it is
probably the most successful CG feather
bird that I've seen on film or
television and that's saying a lot
because we had a photo real aspiration
for something that was known the thing
was either going to look like a real
bird or it wasn't Matthew not only had
to look real but he had to fly move and
interact with the rest of the cast
considering he was once human himself
they had to create facial expressions
that resembled natural human emotion not
a simple task number seven we're all
familiar with the famous John
Constantine that's the reason why he's
not in the show Neil thought he'd been
represented enough in the media so he
pitched the idea to Alan about turning
him into Joanna we both thought about
Jenna and Jenna's voice and that went a
long way just in terms of my conception
who she was they wanted to do a fresh
spin on the character so they took what
they loved about Jon and brought new
life into it and we just had a lot of
fun I think
um on all fronts number eight there were
several Sandman movie and television
pitches that didn't work over the years
Neil Gaiman always felt passionate about
bringing Sandman to life but only if it
could be done in the right way he told
IGN I didn't care about it getting made
I would so much rather that it never got
made than a bad version would get made
even a director he really respects Eric
Kripke pitched a sandman series for
Network TV in 2010. Neil Gaiman had many
reservations about that at the time the
damage that you had to do to Sandman to
put it on network TV 15 years ago and in
the kind of budgets and the way that you
could do it just meant it wasn't Sandman
number nine if you'd read the comics
you'd know how well they pulled this off
when filming the show they really wanted
as many scenes as they could manage to
be like you pulled it straight off the
page what was really thrilling was
remembering how accurately some of those
frames were replicated they always had a
copy of the graphic novel right next to
the camera that was so important to us
when we were making number 10 Ian
Markowitz definitely had his hands full
here something really beautiful but also
incredibly Difficult about the show was
that every episode is different from the
one before it with dream being the only
thing holding the timeline together Ian
shares his experience working on the
show's wide range of sets it's not a
procedural where we're doing similar
things next week there's always
something that's going to be different
about the next episode and three may not
be on screen for every frame of the show
but he is always going to be at the
heart of things
number 11 not even his original Comics
or panels from 1989. we're talking about
the scripts he wrote for artists before
any of that even got onto the page when
Ian Markowitz was brought on as the VFX
supervisor he found the project to be a
bit daunting at first because of how
well known the world of Sandman already
was he describes having been given
Neil's notes as being gifted gold he
explains I thought that starting with
Neil's notes was the perfect way for us
to think about adapting the show because
sometimes the comic book panel is very
comic Booky and it has that wild quirky
zany quality which I don't think the
show has all of that much number 12 not
only did Tom Sturridge go through it
with his look but he also had to
mentally prepare to become the Eternal
being that is Morpheus Neil gave him
some pertinent advice on how dream
carries himself he has thoughts every
thought that could ever be thought it
would ever be conceived of with every
line he said he had to utilize his voice
to convey that message to us therefore
when he speaks it should feel as if it's
etched in stone number 13 if anyone can
do it Neil Gaiman can Neil Gaiman was
the key the Sandman Comics were first
released over three decades ago but the
cult following has remained extremely
dedicated it makes sense that a casual
dinner conversation between Neil Gaiman
Alan heinberg and David goyer would lead
to a Netflix pitch three days later
honestly that sort of felt like okay
well it feels like it would be a TV
first season number 14 they actually had
the cast before the writing was even
finished Alan heinberg was extremely
grateful that the Sandman already had
such a massive following they were able
to cast for it pretty much immediately
having the cast at hand was highly
preferred as Alan likes to write with
the actor's voice in mind one of the
characters that went through the most
transformation on the page was
Corinthian Neil and I decided you know
what we're going to embrace everything
that Boyd is Boyd whole being cast
completely the way they approach the
character and there was a version of
that with this and with everybody in the
cast number 15 there has to be at least
one there are so many Incredible
characters with stories worth following
when talking about the end of Sandman it
makes it much easier for the showrunners
to see the end when you have Source
material you're going off of but
something unknown that excites them are
all the potential series they could
create from other characters there are
death miniseries we'd love to explore
doing there are other characters worthy
of having their own Adventures so after
going through the Practical set designs
comic book replicas costumes and Neil
gaiman's vintage Sandman scripts we're
still completely floored by all the
incredible talent and dedication it took
to bring this series to life
stranger things had trained rats for the
show so why were they fired in this
video we'll be looking behind the scenes
at all the CGI Creations from the show
what did it look like when Millie Bobby
Brown was battling the Mind flayer how
about the special software that made the
rats bubble let's take a look
Millie Bobby Brown puts up a pretty
amazing fight against the Mind flayer
but on the set she definitely had the
upper hand since these wild long and
slimy tentacles weren't actually there
and on the attack Brown's performance
combined with the CGI creatures make
this scene totally believable of course
we can't forget this special monster
attack it's honestly a terrifying moment
but taking a peek behind the scenes we
see the Monster wasn't the slimy mess
that we see but a lump of black material
with some tracking spots on it that gets
thrown off and away
well that's nice we can talk about the
VFX of the Netflix hit without
acknowledging one of the most incredible
CGI Feats of all we're talking about the
Mind flare with the effects brought to
life this creature stands to be one of
the most terrifying there is but behind
the scenes it's a totally different
pictures we can see here with this giant
beach ball at the end of a stick waving
around throughout the set of them all
this blue screen in the middle of the
forest also helped in playing the role
of the Mind flare
check out how much of the shot is
actually entirely CGI created as for
when daker Montgomery faces off with the
monsters instead of the giant creature
coming at him from above we can see that
his enemy is actually angled up from
below and less slimy and uh well more
like a long silver pole with a big black
handle at the end at the other end of
the poll was a stunt man just hidden off
screen all this time we've been building
it while the majority of this monster
was created with CGI behind the scenes
things looked less terrifying and a bit
well uh absurd check out this stunk I
dressed in red with yes that's a
mirrored helmet his running around
flailing arms and screaming looks
ridiculous as is here but when the
effects are all added in we see just how
effective the simulation is for creating
the Tom Bruce monster check him out as
he manages to creepily crawl over
Natalia Dyer his creature-like movements
are perfect for emanating the monster
that would join via CGI part of the
reason for having this physical person
enact the monster was to help the actors
performances while it looks a bit silly
it was clearly super effective and
helped the whole team to bring their a
game oh and as for the mirror helmet it
wasn't just used because of how cool it
looks practically it was used to capture
the light reflecting and how it would
hit the creature a special detail that
really helped make the CGI look real
when the signature Neon Lights of the
Star Court Mall aren't up the building
doesn't look as wonderful and the fact
is it's entirely created by CGI anyway
we can see in the mapping here that
they're making sure to take care of
every single detail these CGI cars
spread throughout the parking lot the
detailed work on the roof and of course
the recognizable bright front entrance
as for the inside of the mall well it's
pretty real but fortunately the Mind
flare didn't do nearly as much damage as
we see in the Final Cut we can see in
this behind the scenes shot that the
destruction of the Mind flares done
mindfully with some practical bits
adjusted here and there the set is
definitely a mess when the monster is
finally defeated there are some obvious
worn and damaged looking remnants we can
see here combine this set with these
incredible special effects and the
result really is amazing
there were some very messy interactions
between the humans and the Monsters
remember all those people that were
flayed each one of them had practical
makeup done but when the monster took
over CGI was key
remember the tentacles latch directly on
these faces it's a terrifying image but
behind the scenes there was a lot of
bling pretend in the actors definitely
did a stellar job at acting as if life
were being taken from them
don't have to do this while there were
loads of incredible CGI Creations
throughout the stranger things series
the Rats of season 3 were Epic
first of all just look at the sheer
number of them scurrying about they look
freakishly real and in fact at one time
they were the team actually had rats
trained and prepared but they turned out
to not be at the same level as the rest
of the performers so these CGI rodents
were brought to life just when we think
we've seen them all somehow more rats
always seem to appear out of nowhere the
amount of detail really adds to how
convincing these scenes look
if we check it out closely we can see
literally every strand of hair whisker
and of course those signature creepy
black beady eyes
then of course are the rats that go
through uh well let's just say a bit of
a tougher time more on those CGI rodents
later
[Music]
why just have regular rats when you can
also have melting and exploding rats
okay maybe we haven't thought that
ourselves but the stranger things team
definitely did remember these melting
creatures in Miss Driscoll's basement
let's just say we preferred them when
they were the regular creepy rats how
did they make these strange and
literally bubbly effects a special
software called Houdini was responsible
for those effects used for the textures
the jam like substance is super creepy
to begin with and then it moves the
effects team put great detail into
simulating a mixture of various items
and of course coated it off with some
slime for good measure did you happen to
notice the Slick Black Tail amongst the
Slime blob it's that kind of extra touch
that really made these creatures perfect
for the world of stranger things the
effects team made sure to get the
approval of the kids at the show too all
of whom thought their creation was
horrifying that's when they knew it was
a winner
remember this dark and stormy Beach it
was much more pleasant when they were
actually shooting
they added these incredible huge rolling
clouds further highlighted by the Reds
blues and purples bursting through with
light creating an extremely intimidating
scene how about this intense fight
it looks like it's right in the middle
of this brutal and blustering storm but
in reality the whole thing wasn't even
taking place on the beach like it was
earlier in the scene this whole sequence
looks so different and way less intense
than the green screen Studio but the
actors do an amazing job with their
performances to make the whole scene
believable the added VFX and CGI just
bring it to that Stellar stranger things
level
bike
this was one of the Duffer brothers's
favorite VFX used in the third season of
stranger things
inside the Russian Lab our minds are
totally blown when we see the high-tech
Machinery going the giant spinning
turbine-like object alone has excellent
effects like the speed of the spinning
lighting within and the way the
mechanism moves as a whole even some
characters like these workers we see are
entirely computer generated though there
was an actual structure that sat in the
place with a Fantastical machine see
this long frame that holds the general
shape of the turbine the team even added
these large silver balls to reflect the
lights realistically so the effects team
had that to work with while adding all
the CGI we see in the final product
the snow in this exterior shot is both
gorgeous and extensive we totally
believe it could be a real place until
we see the CGI magic behind the creation
showing us that it is just that a
totally CGI Creation in order to bring
the scene to life realistically the team
Incorporated things like thousands of
snowflakes floating in the air as well
as using wind simulation so the
blustering landscape looks real looking
closely we can appreciate all the
architectural details added all of this
really completes the incredible computer
generated images
who do you work for every moment Every
Beat is mapped out trying about a month
long process just for that 15 seconds
stranger things is easily one of the
most terrifying shows on Netflix we've
seen demogorgons mind players and now
we've got vechna lurking around waiting
for our Kate Butch CD to skip have you
ever wondered what the show would look
like without the visual effects bringing
these creatures to life let's get into
it okay
special effects
number one
The Duffer Brothers only knew a few
things for certain about the demogorgon
they wanted him to come from another
dimension and have a human body type the
body type was really important to them
because they wanted to be able to put an
actual person inside the costume for
season 1 shooting purposes very quickly
we realize okay so practical isn't
always in season 4 however they brought
in animation the first animation passed
that's when you're seeing what looks
almost like just a gray clay rendering
the first pass is really important
because that's when they can hammer out
the details like how long they want him
to Roar for example after that they get
to the rendering stage that's where the
fun really starts everything they've
shot all the animation and real life
stunts get to coexist together it's
really exciting when those shots finally
come together and all the elements
number two
the demogorgon is one thing but the
actual fight scenes require a different
approach a good portion of time the
demogorgon is just a guy in a green suit
sometimes he would have a tennis ball at
the top of his head to show us how tall
the demogorian was in the scene where
Hopper has his major Showdown with the
demogorgon The Duffer Brothers really
wanted to try and do that entire scene
in one shot but unfortunately because of
how dangerous the stunts were they were
not able to do that we didn't want to be
using CG people on top of a CG so we
weren't able to do it all in one shot
they wanted to protect their stunt team
so they did three big stun sequences and
stitched them all together would you
have been able to tell the Americans are
very tricky number three
it takes a lot of work an entire team of
people in fact to make vechna look as
horrifying as he did the actor Jamie
Campbell Bauer went through an egregious
eight and a half hour prosthetic
application every time he had to play
vechna one thing they couldn't do with
prosthetics though was remove his nose
on each application day we had a black
nose on Jamie with some little white
marking dots so VFX could remove that in
post VFX also added in those creepy
slithering vines coming out of vecina's
back I'm for you
to join me number four
speaking of vacna his eight and a half
hour prosthetic seems to pay off because
the cast was typically very frightened
whenever they chewed a scene with him
zachna was pretty much fully practical
effects and made it easier for me so I'm
not like staring at a man in a green
suit Sadie Singh also spent a great deal
of her time in a harness rehearsing for
her levitation scene right before her
big showdown in the upside down there's
not a lot that you have to do because
it's genuinely just so scary number five
one thing you might not know about
Steve's journey to Watergate was that it
wasn't even shot in a real light it was
shot in a Convention Center in Atlanta
Georgia Joe Kiri recounts diving into a
40-foot Tang specifically Built For This
scene getting to do that sort of stuff
is like true movie magic number six
the insane shootout that destroyed every
inch of the buyer's home was also shot
in one take John Levy the director of
episode 4 was compelled to do it all in
one shot he said it was the most
challenging and most rewarding scene
he's ever directed the whole challenge
with the runner is it requires perfect
synchronicity considering they only had
one choreography session for this scene
it's fair to say they killed it
everybody needed to do their job at a
high high level of near Perfection it's
a doozy number seven
you know that part when fechna's victims
are getting every bone in their body
snapped like a wishbone on Thanksgiving
of course how could you forget it's
quite difficult to watch but
surprisingly not that difficult to
achieve with special effects to break
the fingers it's essentially working
with different layers of a moving hand
within Adobe After Effects for the legs
they utilize a much more practical
approach they need to put their arms
through the pants so they can function
as legs and with the bigger range of
motion of an arm we can now create a
twisting braking movement
Factor
an undead creature of great
[Music]
number eight
the unique thing about stranger things
is how they blend practical effects like
makeup and Prosthetics with VFX in every
scene with VFX they also heavily rely on
the makeup team as we stated earlier
Jamie Campbell Bower worked very closely
with the makeup team so close that he
had his own team of people applying Lube
onto his entire body our last 10-15
minutes should be the four of us
literally getting this product all over
him to make him look really really
glossy number nine
we're all familiar with 11's iconic
nosebleed but have you ever wondered how
they get the blood to flow at the right
time at first corn syrup a lot of it the
only time Millie would get to call
Action on set was when she felt it
dripping from her nose you know my nose
is running with blood so I'm like okay
are we ready it's coming three two
because that didn't always go according
to plan they ended up using CGI blood
for those scenes in later Seasons it's
fun to film but also really stressful
number 10.
the character of Victor had a brutal
disfiguring after his encounter with
vechna in reality we can thank the
brilliant prosthetic work of Barry Gower
for Victor's disturbing look the
sculpture evicts creel's appliance which
you can see the difference in tone where
the appliance finishes just prior to
Robert's hairline the two hour process
was so bad for the team because they
were able to reference actual scars as
opposed to something that is completely
fictional I suppose all evil must have a
home number 11.
11 is me like 11 is just who I am now it
doesn't take very long for the cast to
transform into their characters but
Millie's transformation into 11 is a
little more involved it takes about an
hour to do my old wig my makeup isn't
that crazy at all so judging by this
math you could create at least eight
Elevens in the time it takes to create
one vechna Jamie Campbell Bower we do
not envy you underneath all that molding
clay
number 12. in stranger things the upside
down is just as important as any other
character in the show so how exactly do
they create it a recurring theme we've
seen with The Duffer Brothers is that
they prefer to do things as practical as
they can we realize that in fact the
vision that the brothers had was more
extensive than one can always do
practically when it comes to creating
all of the upside down creatures they
had to call on a team of CGI experts it
starts usually with a sculpture so we
digitally sculpt things so with a
mixture of practical components and a
hard-working visual effects team they
were able to create this stunning world
just beneath our own so now you've seen
it all the blend of real life animation
mounds of Prosthetics and the iconic man
in the green suit the visual effects
team clearly works overtime in Hawkins
CGS it's hard you know when you're
looking at a tennis ball you don't get
the same effect as if you were looking
at a big tall man CGI and visual effects
seem to be an important part of
filmmaking these days With a Little Help
from the actors on screen of course we
love being transported into the world of
a story through great VFX work and we
probably love watching what scenes look
like without CGI equally as much stick
around for a look at Inola home scenes
with and without CGI you get to have all
sides of the spectrum all in one movie
and it's really exciting number one hold
on to them
Inola homes features an intense sequence
on a moving train which had actors
Millie Bobby Brown and Lewis Partridge
performing a number of stunts while
walking the line between practical and
digital effects shooting the train was
tricky enough with the complicated VFX
involved but this take went down the
drain because of a simple old-fashioned
fan blowing Millie's hat off
never been sleeping off this train
doesn't it
number two the acting is key the Enola
homes team can make the train look like
it's really speeding through the hills
but if the actors don't sell that
they're really on it the illusion falls
apart here's how actor Lewis Partridge
prepares in the moment to transport
himself to the world of a speeding train
in Enola homes listen to music that was
my trick and get your breath right and
then they say action and you go and then
when you're looking at Millie and you're
both giving the same sort of energy
that's when it flows right visual
effects supervisor Michael Ellis said
that it had to feel like they were
really on the train which is quite a
hard thing to do and when we think about
it we have to agree the timing of the
Practical effects like wind or even just
the gentle rocking of the train can
easily go wrong and spoil a take when
you add in all the other moving Parts
shooting a sequence on a train is a
bigger challenge than it might first
appear Michael Ellis added of course you
can't really shoot on a a real moving
train it's a bit dangerous and kind of
heavy and people fall over we decided to
shoot it in a studio with a green screen
stage number three you gotta believe
with all the CGI involved you might be
surprised to hear that stunt performers
were used at all in this sequence Lewis
Partridge explains that he was not able
to do his own stunts when it came to
jumping off the train I'm not the Tom
Cruise that I thought I might be they
used a stunt man called James he has all
the bruises to take home James if you're
out there we are feeling for you right
now that rolled down the hill looked
rattling to say the least even jumping
off of a fake moving train can be
dangerous
it just went crazy number four
everything else seems to be CGI have a
look at this scene in the various stages
of development as it gets more complex
it looks like part of the digital scene
was made from scans of a real
environment while things like the train
were built from computers alone we had
the digital landscape we had the Digital
River and we had our digital characters
down the hill as well that's a very
digital movie they were like
number five remember them using CGI and
digital effects to create part of the
world of a story is a powerful tool but
using too much of it can make things
feel like they're a little off so what
do we do add real people back into the
scene of course after the careful
process of mapping out this scene and
creating elements that would make it
convincing as an actual place in the
world it was time to add the actors back
in with an outdoor shot I really enjoyed
the Practical sets number six goofing
around on sets seems to follow Millie
Bobby Brown around green screen Studios
and visual effects are important for the
experience of Enola homes but so is the
human Elements which sometimes means the
performance and other times means
keeping it real by goofing around on set
watch how fast Millie can floss
it's quite cool and with all that green
screen around just imagine the
possibilities
someone's got to take advantage of that
you know I really wanted to see a lead
female British lead number seven think
you'll like The View when we think green
screen and visual effects we often think
big immersive complicated expensive but
often it's the little things that can
make the biggest differences take this
scene for example where that famous
green color can be seen only through the
window of the room where Enola is
practicing her posture with that book on
her head or this scene where the only
green screen we're actually seeing is
for the skyline or some store signs
true youth
number eight oh yes there's more when we
think of cable stunts we tend to think
more about Spider-Man than Enola Holmes
but believe it or not actor Lewis
Partridge is actually dangling from a
cable while on a harness in this scene
just when he's on the brink of falling
out of the train Millie Bobby Brown
actually got her hand caught in the
cable when trying to perform the action
of pulling him back through the door if
we look at this scene without CGI when
Lewis is dangling from the open door you
might notice it was actually the camera
that was on Rails speeding along and not
the train I'm not ready to die on a
train I'm not ready to die at all and I
wasn't going to before I met you number
nine who knows at this point the visual
effects team on Enola Holmes knew they
needed to have the door come off the
train for the tunnel sequence to make
this happen they needed to match the
real door with a CG door so they started
with the real door in studio map to the
camera movements and the actor's action
carefully and then recreated the real
life door and matched it perfectly with
the CG version of itself
number 10 do you believe
visual effects and CGI can have us
thinking of elaborate changes to a scene
but often it can alter just a few
details that take us a little further
into believing in the world of the story
in this scene you can see just a hint of
that signature green color indicating
that production was intending to change
something there was it a sky reflecting
the mood of the scene or maybe a store
sign with a hidden clue or message on it
number 11. Inola homes features plenty
of Shining Moments where digital meets
physical sometimes the most entertaining
visual effects are just physical
performance but just like creating an
elaborate CGI sequence physical effects
take plenty of preparation often that
can mean training and rehearsal I'm like
really careful yeah I'm I'm very good
take this fight scene here's what it
looks like in rehearsal with all the
visual elements Stripped Away I train
for roles that's what I do I love
training for roles no number 12. Millie
Bobby Brown got more than her hands
dirty in this action sequence check out
this behind the scenes footage where
Enola Holmes wearing her new dress gets
into a scuffle with the bowler hat in
the muddy Streets of London in case you
were wondering that mud is real it's all
singing hard and tiring but I actually
really enjoyed it Millie went so far as
to tease someone on set with the
possibility of a very muddy wet hug we
wonder how many copies of this dress
they wound up having on hand
very very excited to be able to film it
we love watching how great CGI work can
transport an audience into the world of
the story I know it is that for me and
it's been an amazing experience creating
it and we definitely love watching the
behind the scenes just as much so what
do you think
you wanna go first you go it just takes
a village to make the gray mask the gray
man is set to surpass any expectations
you may have with nine intense action
sequences a stacked cast and a
ridiculous budget the Russo brothers are
shooting to create a new action
franchise ready to find out just how
they brought it all together number one
Joe compared this situation to a Monty
Python skit there was a car on a swivel
in front of a green screen and the
russos told Ryan to lay down and just
hang on as if the car was spinning at a
very high speed all they had to do was
shake it a bit it wasn't going the way
Joe hoped so he climbed on the car to
show Gosling how it's done hopefully we
get to see the secret take they filmed
number 2. Gosling went through all the
different martial arts Styles I've never
made an action movie before so it's it
was a lot for me of course the movie is
designed around him so it was all on his
shoulders seven months were devoted to
intense highly specialized choreography
the russos were a couple of teases to
Gosling too they were eating like kings
while he was eating some quote dried
chicken breast thing Joe's never met
anyone who could do stunts like Chris
Evans at least until Gosling
number three you should always be
cautious of what they save for the end
of filming take Ryan Gosling's word for
it he said when I was on the tram it was
nearly the end of filming I'm running on
top of these tram cars and they're
falling beneath my feet as I jump I
remember thinking this sums up this
experience this is exactly what this
movie has felt like number four despite
the nine action sequences the cast went
pretty unscathed it was like a knock
down drag out every day kind of thing
but no emotional scars Joe Russo said
that Gosling was getting beat up
sequence after sequence and was weirdly
loving it while Chris Evans got into a
little hustle with the gray man and
battered his arm pretty bad deobia Opera
trained for four months for a 10 minute
sequence I was like oh pain
oh no baby okay have fun number five
watch out for her the training was
really like 360 training Anna said you
have to create this Unity on set and you
have to to match the other person's
energy and you need to be very careful
and give the other person the space to
also feel safe and go at their own speed
she's she's dangerous she's a dangerous
person be careful number six keep in
mind the average is four nine action
sequences is just insane the idea was to
create a Relentless experience for the
audience Joe and Anthony are entertained
by excess the novel The movie is based
on has 11 action sequences Joe had no
idea how they were going to fit it all
into one film but they managed to pare
it down to nine number seven Chris ran
mustache first into this part so said
Ryan Gosling while evans's character
manifests as a sociopath he doesn't see
it that way he sees him as someone
Fearless being his authentic self Chris
believes that usually villains aren't
burdened by complexities and
insecurities number eight this movie had
barely any deleted scenes maybe a line
was cut here in there but these guys
were in a tight ship the russos have a
very disciplined approach to working on
a script they're more than willing to
cut things before they get filmed rather
than do all that work and cut it later
because energy is precious number nine
from grayscale to a rainbow of
Awesomeness they wanted an extravagant
amount of color to contrast the lead
character Joe said the way that we
approached the look and feel of the
movie was in contrast to the expectation
they played with different techniques to
keep the lead out of focus by putting
him in a weird part of the frame
lighting him slightly less or keeping
the focus off of him which Anthony said
sort of created the idea of a ghost-like
quality number 10 the whole cast was put
through the ringer okay I've worked for
these x amount of months let's see what
we got Joe admitted it's extremely
physical it can be painful there's a
Cirque du Soleil level of choreography
going on people are throwing punches at
each other at very high speed and if
somebody misses by an inch someone has a
broken jaw it requires incredible
precision and a lot of training number
11. the russos are giving us a slightly
different kind of action star Joe said
he's a very modern hero he's existential
he's obsessed with Sisyphus the Greek
myth of this character stuck in futility
it's what separates him from Bond and
born as Ryan said it's a proletariat
hero he just wants to get the job done
and go home and he has no desire to
romanticize it number 12. despite your
best efforts sometimes you have to make
a cut filming the hospital scene took
weeks before they'll release the actors
for the day they watch the footage to
make sure it's working and if it isn't
they get back to work they tried a ton
of different ideas on this one it's the
only one where any real Cuts happened
because they were so experimental with
it
see there
number 13. their process is almost like
cheating surround yourself with good
people and you only have to do half the
work the other half of the work is great
communication Anna found she had freedom
to explore during rehearsal times find
out what she was and wasn't comfortable
with and then they built the fight
scenes around her and her ability number
14 we're not talking about the hissing
Cobra chicken's devil spawn still just
Ryan Gosling got the call when the
pandemic hit about some globetrotting
epic Blockbuster for Netflix he didn't
think it was serious but reality hit
when he got his call time he always
wanted to make an action film it took a
long time to find the right one but he
knew that this was it because the russos
were Manning the helm number 15. the
Russo Brothers have been obsessed with
Ryan for the last two decades just like
everybody else his character craves
anonymity but when he talks the
character has to be quirky and funny Joe
finds it hard to find an actor who
possesses Ryan's range because Ryan's
incred incredible with minimalism able
to convey an entire interior life with
just a few looks number 16. keep in mind
John Wick only cost 25 million to make
this is Netflix's most expensive film
ever costing 200 million dollars this
partially had to do with all of the
cities that made gorgeous backdrops for
the film including Chateau de Shanti in
France Los Angeles the Czech Republic
Thailand Austria and Azerbaijan we shot
an awful lot of it in a hangar in Long
Beach between the locations and the nine
action sequences that take up three
quarters of the film they really racked
up the bill number 17 dynamic characters
is the name of the casting game Joe
called Anna a badass who can embody her
character in an extremely truthful way
Anthony said she had to create a very
rich inner life where we can follow her
thoughts and we can see her calculating
her way through challenges number 18. so
the stunt coordinator has an excellent
sense of fashion of course they have a
martial arts school in Orange County and
that's their tracksuit number 19. let's
just say the russos could have used 48
hours in a day the movie almost did end
the two of them they were so tired by
the end of it because action requires an
intense level of thought care and
execution on set but of course the
action wasn't their only responsibility
they were also editing at night and
re-crafting constantly so they weren't
sleeping number 20. here's hoping this
is the end of these pandemic Tales of
whoa huh and Jessica just like kind of
possibly notes under the floor saying
hey can we be friends there was a lot of
ad hoc building of environments due to
the pandemic and I'd send back a little
note full of hearts saying no the gray
man is shaping up to be the action movie
of the year and for good reason huh we
got Choppers now wait 11 sitting down a
chopper with mind Volume 2 of stranger
things managed to pack everything we
love about the series into two compact
little episodes we're taking a look
inside the hive mind at how they managed
to pull off their most intense episodes
to date it's gonna feel very different
it's going to feel very big it'll be
like season one you know on steroids or
something number one it's no secret that
the cast of stranger things is Top Notch
well our favorite cast of kids uh young
adults are also phenomenal improvisers
from witty quotable new lines to subtle
little changes the urgency and honesty
these actors bring is next level like
Caleb McLaughlin crying out to his
sister there we go
it's a sweet and tragic moment of
vulnerability for Lucas another pretty
super moment was Finn's improvisation
during his monologue which he only
needed to shoot a few times by the way
because he's a true Pro you're my
superhero and the Brotherly Love Is in
the Air between Eddie Munson and Dustin
Henderson I love you Dad
the future this tear-jerking moment was
all gut instinct our stuff together is
is so poignant and important to driving
his character number two behind the
scenes of the creel house had far fewer
tripping hazards it's like Hopscotch
over imaginary Vines trying to step
around all those Vines was less dramatic
because they weren't there the actors
were just trying to hit their Mark in
other words tape on the floor there was
no robe or anything standing in for the
vines so when Robin was strung up
against the wall Maya was just having to
hold her arms in the air for a very long
time Joe broke the freaking camera
during one take because he had to swing
an ax close to it but accidentally
Struck it went directly into camera
through this filter into the front and
the shot was amazing number three did
you know that the voice of vechna is all
real don't believe us just check out
Jamie Campbell Bower in the recording
booth I saw a means to realize my
potential unlike how daker Montgomery
had his voice altered and changed adding
a little unsettling and ominous tone
when he was taken over by the Mind
flayer now we can all see Jamie's voice
was all his to transcend my human for
eign there was no need for Jaime to
transcend his human form
I need
Ed anything
number four thanks to extra time we got
a ton of Eddie Joseph Quinn knows his
way around a guitar but they did have
another guitarist to come in and do that
epic solo regardless Eddie Munson's fate
wasn't always tied to his guitar but as
they talked about his ending it became
clear it's what they needed to do they
were able to go back to earlier episodes
because none of them had been shot yet
and layer in the guitar layer in his
band usually they write about four
scripts and are already shooting as the
next chunk of scripts are being written
Joseph Quinn was pretty gutted when he
found out they were quite literally
gutting his character but it was one
Epic send-off and he couldn't really be
mad about that most surprising or
surreal pause uh experience number five
what seemed like a simple shot still
took a very long time Matt Duffer said
we were very much inspired by Empire
Strikes Back That ending where they're
looking out the window we wanted to hint
at the notion of war and and a
supernatural War coming to Hawkins the
cast and crew spent an entire super hot
day out there just to get this one shot
the most exhausting thing but doing it
together was the best number six we know
what you're thinking how was this show
Disney inspired well the inspiration for
the creel house was actually the Haunted
Mansion ride from Disneyland because
Sean Levy doesn't enjoy horror they gave
him the required viewing list in
addition to a music playlist so he did
have a crash course in horror haunted
house fluency abilities we have as
storytellers have grown every year
number seven flipping stereotypes on
their head was the goal The Writer's
room really enjoyed taking characters
and then doing role reversals playing
against the stereotypes humanizing
people like Eddie Munson and Chrissy you
don't remember me I'm sorry of course
this has been going on since season one
the actors are really grateful for this
as well because it has led to such
interesting and dynamic characters
we're the freaks because we like to play
a fantasy game number eight honestly we
might have just turned the TV off if
they didn't max for good they had a ton
of discussions about what they wanted to
do but it became very important for
season five that Max being a coma this
season was influenced heavily by Empire
Strikes Back of course and so Max's coma
was an attempted parallel to Han Solo
being frozen in carbonite do you think
that came across at all
here Max
number nine sometimes the nonsensical
offing of characters heads just isn't
necessary the Russian double Crosser
Enzo almost met a tragic fate in a
previous draft of the script but
honestly there was no reason for it it
didn't move the plot along so why not
give this guy his happy ending too and
more Star Wars references the demo bats
were inspired by the parasitic minoc
bats in The Empire Strikes Back in an
earlier draft the demo bats had serrated
tail tentacles that were meant to wrap
and then cut flesh if they had this
trait they could have too easily killed
Steve another design was way too similar
to the demo dogs and demogorgons because
its head and body split open the same
way I really like that stuff and as the
show has gone on I've gotten to do more
and more of it number 10 crafting the
big Baddie is always time consuming work
vecno went through a ton of different
concept art the first designed to haunt
your nightmares is the one of him with
hair and a pathetic excuse for a face
you can see the evolution of one idea
from the initial fish inspiration to
giving him a spiky coat of armor the
praying mantis design is awesome but it
wasn't exactly a practical design for
filming either because of its long legs
and The Duffer brothers were really
leaning towards vechna being practical
the alien designs were direct
inspiration from the demogorgons and
demo dogs and would have tied him in
aesthetically with the rest of the
upside down creatures these designs
while amazing in theory just didn't
disguise Henry well enough or didn't
allow for enough expression
move my fingers around really slow
moving them fast enough as I'm excited
number 11 floating rocks it's too
complicated at one point the particles
were going to be harvested from floating
rocks it had a lot to do with how
gravity worked differently in this realm
but it was too lengthy to try and
explain
probably the coolest alternate design
for vechna's Lair was a later one more
in line with the spider theme where his
victims were hanging from the vine like
it was a spider web
change Us number 12. it's got to be a
great feeling when some of the greats
want to work with you Robert Englund
sent in an audition tape of himself
lying in a bathtub fully clothed mind
you pouring his heart out so no it
wasn't the stranger things team's idea
to bring in Freddy Krueger but it was a
perfect pairing number 13 The Stranger
Things cast are just so melodramatic we
actually went on a 45 minute walk that
day do you remember the day in question
was the end for 11's Papa they walked
all the way from the base camp through
the middle of the desert because they
were sad Millie did love the boldness of
11 to not wrap up her complicated
relationship with her papa by giving him
what he wanted in those last moments
[Music]
number 14 the style of the show still
throws the actors for a loop a lot of
the time they're thinking okay so we're
about to face this big bad evil thing
we're scared right and The Duffer
brothers are like yeah like like you're
pretty confident the leather in the
characters is really just rejuvenating
for the actors who if they were stuck in
a place of constant Terror might just
find the show not so fun to film number
15. we're not talking about vechna's
clocks but Netflix's they were cutting
it close to time with adding the final
VFX actually their time was so bad that
if you tuned in to watch Volume 2 right
upon release there were a few VFX shots
that weren't done yet and people were
encouraged not to watch until the
morning when they would be complete
wanna see something cool was it or
wasn't it CG from the hovercrafts to
flipping cars to a fully built and then
entirely replaced set the atom project
knew how to make the best of their
special and practical effects
number one
the fights were real CG just made them
better one of the most complicated
fights choreo wise was when Zoe Kravitz
and Ryan Reynolds were reunited and
battling side by side with the trusty
blue screen behind them to touch up the
image in post when Reynolds needed his
lightsaber sorry his mag still CG took
care of the magic making him look as
slick as he was acting while CG replaced
their bodies and Tech on set those
actors battling Reynolds really were
suited up and tough and futuristic
looking gear
number two
it wasn't always safe but they pulled it
off the set was stunts Galore and
everyone took part even newcomer Walker
scoble who got up close and personal
with a harness and wires that allowed
him to safely land his first superhero
pose It Wasn't So Glamorous for the
other Adam who straight up dealt with a
rough car smack
number three
little Adams says it best
defensive Kravitz may have pulled the
trigger boom but it was the VFX
Specialists who made the explosions we
see Next Level just because CG was
playing a part didn't mean the team was
going to skip out on the chance to use a
real car for their stunt though the
effects just cleaned the image up blue
screens were all around the giant
practical set giving the actors space to
perform the intense choreo they worked
on for months while CG brought the fire
wherever and whenever needed
number four
shockingly a ton of the chase scene
isn't CGI that's right 50 of what we see
on screen throughout the big chase fight
was 100 really done and that included
the hovercraft Racers and I said can we
actually do that for real luckily the
answer was yes we surfed these guys
through the woods in British Columbia
sitting inside the truck zooming through
the woods did involve a truck racing not
so much you guys shot on a green screen
stage in a truck in front of green
screen and then there's the hole
launching out of the ship moment that
happened completely in studio with
performers rigged up safely in front of
a special blue screen and hooked up to a
real hoverboard except for this shot the
boards took a back seat and let the VFX
team do the heavy lifting
number five we're talking sorian Style
it's called a MAG still look it up you
can't because it's not real they may be
sorry in weapons but these intricate and
fascinating looking tools were actually
created by a small company called super
Vixen all the way down under in
Australia I feel like there's that basic
thrill of seeing something you haven't
seen before all the design pieces were
3D printed and put together no easy feat
considering there were over 200 pieces
to put together in total for the scene
it sees weapons and tools flying through
the air the visual effects team used the
custom design tools as a base and then
mock them up digitally for the final
edit
number six what you see isn't always
what you get or is it I told the VFX
team I need some kind of program that
allows me to see the
the high tech and Spacey looking office
was a totally constructed set in a giant
blue studio one that allowed the actors
to really immerse themselves in the
world and Technology it's really opened
up shot design possibilities in a real
way and from angles that I can't even
get to Mark Ruffalo made sure to take
advantage of the fact that he could
actually interact with the set while all
the detail was great for the actors to
work with it wasn't totally up to
scratch for the final edit so the whole
Lab was digitally replaced in post but
based on the design that was built in
real life
number seven
spontaneously appearing aircraft no
biggie but really first of all none of
that was there you heard her say it no
real spacecrafts were harmed in the
making of This film since there were no
ships to be harmed the skies were all
clear so the editing team had a solid
base to bring the ship to life via CG
and a pretty wicked looking one at that
let's just go home please
number eight
we've never seen Catherine Keener
looking like this before and hopefully
we won't again considering what we got
on screen was not at all a true to life
version of a younger Keener this deep
fake didn't totally work out as instead
of relying on makeup and Prosthetics the
actress was given a CG face put over top
her actual face making porcelain
seriously uncanny valley vibes I
say future de-aging is tricky but we
definitely prefer Keener without the CG
then why are you back here now aside
from the one CG face misstep the special
effects team for the atom project went
above and beyond to elevate this film to
the next level got it the atom project
did you think all the hovercraft action
was full cg2 who knew
thank you